hello and welcome to my second php
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be discussing
echo and a little bit more depth echo is
built into php and it's used to output
things to the user's browser which is
done through html which really html and
php are going to interact
pretty heavily if you're going to be
doing
any sort of really web development so
initially what we did was we echoed out
welcome to php
um here and this was just kind of like a
basic
echo of text but you can also
start echoing out html tags if you're
not familiar with html
you can just follow along there's really
no epic html stuff coming up anytime
soon so
um so we'll just throw on some html tags
and
so to do that strong
we'll save this and we'll upload it back
to
the server and we'll pop over here we'll
refresh
oh we had misspelled our tag
save it one more time upload that back
to the server one last time
refresh and now we have a bolded
welcome to php very strong
there is another way to output text and
that is with print
so as you'll see we'll save this we'll
upload this back to the server
and actually let's let's add another
period just so you you can believe me
that i've uh
changed the file upload that back to the
server will come here
hit refresh and as you can see it's the
same thing it really their
print and echo are one in the same
echo is just a little bit less um
processing heavy it's what you're going
to see most of the time
i can't say i've ever really seen
someone's php script that used print
so anyway use echo but if you did see
print hopefully you now know
what print would even mean
with echo you can also use
um you can put variables into this and
we'll go into
detail with variables a little bit more
later but let's just
name a variable and to name a variable
use a dollar sign
then the variable name and we'll go over
some more rules for variable names in
in probably one of the next videos but
for now we'll just say
it's equal to php um and then so you can
do
uh welcome to and let's get rid of these
strong
tags so welcome to and then you use a
period and that kind of just denotes
what's called it's well it's a full stop
and then you can add things to it so
let's actually add a space at the end of
the string and then we'll just
put lang so it's kind of like you're
appending
laying whatever the variable lang is to
the string
but basically what i'm trying to show
you is that you can use um
echo with you know not only strings in
html but you can input
variables into that as well so if we
come back over here and refresh
and we've got given ourselves some sort
of error lovely
oh we didn't okay i taught i told you in
the first tutorial i'm going to forget
con
or semicolons all the time and uh
i've only begun so anyway so here's our
welcome to php and this time
you know the php part is actually this
lang
so that's just a quick to show you
the echo and again you can use print but
don't use print
and so in the next tutorial what i'm
going to be showing you guys is
a little bit more in depth about
implementing php with html
so as always thanks for watching and
until next time